confronté à sa première crise
internationale justin trudeau veut
projeter l'image le premier ministre
confiant et déterminé face au terrorisme
sur la même longueur d'onde que ses
alliés
c'est très très clair qu'il ya une
volonté et du gouvernement canadien et
de la population de voir tous les
efforts faits contre l'état islamique et
le canada va continuer de s'engager de
façon appropriée or au moment même où
deux cf 18 canadiens viennent
d'effectuer de nouvelles frappes
aériennes en irak
justin trudeau persiste et signe ils
rentreront au pays avant fin prévue de
la mission en mars prochain
le canada va procéder de façon
responsable en travaillant de concert
avec nos alliés
le premier ministre fait valoir que les
forces canadiennes seront plus utiles
dans un autre rôle que celui des
bombardements la formation des troupes
locales au sol demeure sa priorité il
c'est l'expertisé développée en
afghanistan c'est là dit il que nous
serons le plus utile pour contrer les
terroristes
li membre du g20 demeure confrontée à
l'épineuse question comment réussir
enfin à défaire le groupe armé état
islamique
le président obama a rejeté l'idée
d'envoyer des troupes de combat au sol
ici tous s'entendent pour dire que les
efforts militaires ne suffiront pas
les tractations donc se poursuivre pour
trouver une solution politique pour
mettre fin à la guerre en syrie
mais d'ici là la crise des réfugiés
continuent de s'intensifier
là aussi justin trudeau demeure ferme
son gouvernement s'est toujours en
accueillir 25 milles avant corps le 1er
janvier mais ça ne change
notre engagement et notre croyance ferme
que le canada peut et doit en faire plus
justin trudeau dont confirme que son
conseil des ministres est en train
d'élaborer les nouveaux paramètres de la
participation du canada à la coalition
contre le groupe armé état islamique
un enjeu qui sera certainement abordée
lors de sa première rencontre formelle
avec le président des etats-unis barack
obama a manié judy ici emmanuelle
latraverse radio canada antalya en
turquie